ARTUR OLIVEIRA: All right.
Well, good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you all so
much for coming out.
My name is Artur Oliveira.
I'm on the Talks at Google team.
And I'm very excited today to
welcome Nick Balla and Cortney
Burns to a Zagat
Guest Chef series.
Nick and Cortney are
the co-executive chefs
of Bar Tartine in San
Francisco's Mission District.
Now, Tartine is a very
celebrated restaurant
in the city, because
it uses a menu that
is really hard to classify.
But as these guys like to
say, it is easy to describe.
So there's lots of very
interesting influences--
Eastern European, Japanese,
lots of other different parts
of the world.
So if you could
all please help me
welcome Nick and Cortney for
our Guest Chef series today.
[APPLAUSE]
NICK BALLA: Thanks
for having us.
CORTNEY BURNS: Thank you.
NICK BALLA: So we're here today.
We just finished a cookbook, so
we're kind of celebrating that.
There's a lot of
different stuff in there.
Kind of the main
point of that and what
we do at the restaurant is
based on how we make things.
So we process most
of the stuff in house
at the restaurant, all
the way from the dairy
program to cured meats, drying
of things like fruit or paprika
powder.
Really, we try to make
whatever we can in
house for use for our recipes.
So the first, like, huge
chunk of the cookbook
is based on how to make
some of the things.
By all means, you don't
have to, but it's just
kind of a fun possibility.
We were thinking about
what to make here today,
and we were thinking, do we
go, like, fancy and try to do,
like, tweezer food, or--
CORTNEY BURNS: Which we
don't really know how to do.
NICK BALLA: Right.
So that was a bad idea.
Instead, we're doing a
couple of the things that
are our favorite things to
eat-- all-time favorite things
to eat.
There's a salad that we're
making with sweet potato
and avocado, pickled
green walnuts,
which we process in large
batches every spring when
the walnuts are under-ripe.
We'll do 90, 120 liters
of those every spring.
Hopefully, it'll
last the whole year.
That salad's kind
of based on one
of Cortney's favorite
snacks, which
was-- what was it originally?
CORTNEY BURNS: It's like yogurt
and sweet potato with avocado,
really kind of like a
refrigerator mishmash.
A lot of times, our food
is inspired that way,
where we're making
something that we really
are craving in the moment
and fulfilling that craving.
We eat what we feel like eating.
And then figure out if it
works and if it's delicious,
which [INAUDIBLE] we're
gonna go 50-50 on that one.
How we can transition it into
working in the restaurant.
How can we serve it
to you guys so you
feel like you're getting
a restaurant dish and not
something that I pulled out
of the refrigerator at home.
So this dish was
actually the followup
of something like that.
And we were writing
the book, where
we spent more time at home
than we normally ever do,
just because we could actually
focus on the book a little bit.
We would kind of
split our days up
and write, which was a
very interesting process.
So this came together one
day while writing the book,
actually.
And had lunch, told Nick, I
had this great lunch today.
And then we kind of
turned into this salad.
It definitely was not
this salad to begin with,
but it was the kind of inspiring
moment to create the salad.
And that's how a lot of our food
is created, either from flavor
memories or foods
that we've just
eaten that we want to
recreate or kind of evolve.
So that's how that
one came about.
NICK BALLA: We ended
up adding-- she'll
go over the ingredients more.
CORTNEY BURNS: Once we-- yeah.
NICK BALLA: Yeah, as
we're getting into it.
But homemade feta cheese
and then those green walnuts
and mung bean sprouts, which
we sprout at the restaurant.
It's really fun.
This mess here is kapustnica, is
what the Slovak word for it is.
It's always been my
personal favorite thing
to eat at home for,
like, many years.
My dad always made this
when I was growing up.
He lived in central Europe
but learned it there.
So in Slovakia, they
make it for Christmas.
But they also make it
all year, and there
are thousands of
different possible ways
to do it, based on what's
available, where you live,
what you like.
So you can really kind of
evolve it to your taste.
But the point of it
is kind of agrodolce.
And it's always got
spice, sour, sweet,
acidity-- so that kind of
notion of just a lot of flavor.
And it's a really satisfying and
simple thing to make at home.
Always has a base of sauerkraut.
Usually has some
type of cured meat.
Often, at Christmastime,
they don't actually
serve actual meat protein.
It'll just be,
like, a meat stock.
But usually dried
fruit, which brings
out-- dried and fresh fruit,
which gives it sweetness.
Mushrooms, earth.
And then we like
peppers and tomatoes
and all different kinds
of things in here.
We're going to start
making this one first,
because it takes a little
while to simmer everything.
The recipe that we have in
the cookbook-- and it says,
we encourage people to
use things that you like
and what's available.
So there's a recipe
for it, but we also
encourage people to think
outside the box and just
kind of use things
that they like.
You can also do things in
stages and kind of time
it out, so that the
potatoes cook just right.
Or you can dump it
all in the pot, which
is always the way
we do it at home.
And it turns out just great.
So let's get started.
CORTNEY BURNS: This soup is
really-- first of all, again,
back to our house refrigerator,
when Nick takes a day off,
this is usually what I'll find
next day, which is usually
the day I take off in the
refrigerator afterwards.
It's definitely the
comfort food of our house,
as a result of it being
Nick's favorite food.
He can eat this whole pot,
pretty much, of this soup.
But we dump everything in here.
But when we make it
at the restaurant,
we'll often, like Nick was
saying, do it in stages.
And what that does--
and a lot of the food
that we cook at the
restaurant is really
based on layering
lots of flavors.
So sometimes we'll put
certain pork products in first
to pull out the fat and then
start adding and blooming
spices.
But like he said, it's just
as delicious like this.
One of the things in the
cookbook that we really
encourage people to do is play.
And we want people to cook the
food that we have in the book.
So if we were to give
you 15 steps on a soup,
that can turn out
just as delicious
by tossing it all into one bowl.
We encourage you to
just kind of go for it.
NICK BALLA: So we put in bacon,
potatoes, and the dried sausage
first.
So it's kind of like
a dried-- in Hungary,
we made versions of this.
Also, my dad lived there
and we're Hungarian.
It's this goulash sauce.
It's just like a cold, smoked,
really dry-- but like dried
Spanish chorizos is perfect.
That's what this is, basically.
It has a real distinct aroma,
that dried paprika sausage.
CORTNEY BURNS: A lot of
cookbooks and recipes,
if that's something that
you read and follow a lot,
you'll see people rendering
bacon down to pull the fat out.
That is one way to work with
bacon or cured pork products.
Just by way of putting
it in this way,
we're creating heat, which
will pull out some of that fat.
But what we're
doing is we're kind
of making more of a luscious
pork belly out of it.
So instead of kind of crispy
and extracting everything,
we're going to
leave it in there.
It will seize a little bit
just because of the heat,
but it also allows us just to
kind of leave the bacon nice
and tender.
Different mouth feel.
We going for it on all this?
NICK BALLA: Get it.
CORTNEY BURNS: Great.
We like to use sweet onions.
You'll notice in
the grocery store,
sometimes you can
just buy white onions,
or you can buy kind of
yellow, sweet onions.
I'm making a mess over here.
We encourage the sweet
onions, because they
don't have as sharp of an
aroma and they work really
well in soups and stews.
And then raw as well.
We eat a lot of raw
onion in our world.
NICK BALLA: We're
making a lot of soup.
CORTNEY BURNS: We are
NICK BALLA: We always overcook.
CORTNEY BURNS: It's
kind of a problem.
So you guys have to stay
here until it's gone today,
so hopefully there's no pressing
projects at the desk side.
And while we're talking, if
anyone has any questions,
feel free, like, to
ask, be interactive.
You don't have to
be shy with us.
You can help us to
attempt to entertain you
by entertaining us.
So all of that is encouraged.
AUDIENCE: What did
you just dump in?
CORTNEY BURNS:
There is sauerkraut
that we just dumped in, with
some of the brine left on it.
And the sauerkraut that
we make at the restaurant
is just cabbage,
salt, and that's it.
So we shave the cabbage,
which opens up the cell walls,
and that allows us
to just dry salt it.
So there's a couple
different ways
that you can brine
ferment vegetables.
There's many different ways.
Two of the ones
that we use a lot.
These are apples, by the
way, that are going in.
We dry salt, and we
also brine ferment.
So by dry salting
it-- sorry, I don't
have a radar on
this thing-- --we
can extract the liquid
from the vegetables
by opening up all those
cell walls for really
juicy, watery vegetables.
Things like whole
beets or other things
like that, which are
larger, that we ferment,
we then make a salt
brine and pour over it.
So this one has been dry-salted.
So nothing except for
cabbage, salt on that one.
And time, not with an H,
but just like actual time.
This stock is just such
a blonde chicken stock.
So unroasted bones.
Just gently simmered
with whatever vegetables
we had left over
at the restaurant.
I don't know if we're
going to fit in here.
It's getting serious.
NICK BALLA: We got it.
We got it.
AUDIENCE: I couldn't
help but notice
when you were
cutting up the bacon,
you kind of scraped the knife a
little bit on the cutting board
as you moved it aside.
So you know, prep
techniques, I've
heard some people say
that, like, it's really bad
to kind of do that
and it's bad practice.
But that's kind of
what I'm used to doing.
What do you guys think on that?
CORTNEY BURNS: Well,
I don't usually
scrape it directly
against the wood.
A lot of times, I'll
just move things with it,
but, I mean, you can
always sharpen your knife.
It's like, it's
there to be used.
AUDIENCE: So it doesn't
make you a bad chef?
CORTNEY BURNS: You tell me.
I mean, I have no idea.
If you think so, then we're
totally-- we're all good.
No, no.
I don't think it does.
There's so many
schools of thought
on how to use your knives and
how to work with your tools.
By all means, like, we should
treat them with respect,
but they are tools
at the same time.
I mean, hammers are
meant to be used.
Knives are meant to be used.
And so, if I have a knife that's
so delicate that I can't rub it
across the board,
it's probably not one
that I should be
using for that task.
So we pick and
choose our knives,
depending on what
we're doing with them.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Relieved
to hear you say that.
NICK BALLA: There are no rules.
CORTNEY BURNS: Yeah.
And if someone kicks you
out of their kitchen,
you just go back to your own.
It's more fun there anyways.
But I mean,
definitely, there are
kind of the right
tool for the job.
And there are
certain knives that
are not to be used for
opening, like, plastic bags
and things like that,
really, any of them.
Nick won't trust
you on that one.
He likes to use my knives
for things like that.
NICK BALLA: Yup.
CORTNEY BURNS: So we're going
to put a hefty amount of garlic
in here, because we
really like garlic
and we support the
use of lots of allium.
So just prepare yourselves.
I think that's probably good.
Think I should just go for it?
NICK BALLA: Anybody have any
important face-to-face stuff
today?
CORTNEY BURNS: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Mine got cancelled.
CORTNEY BURNS: Perfect.
NICK BALLA: Lucky for them.
AUDIENCE: Will this end
up being more like a stew?
CORTNEY BURNS: A stew
insomuch that we're
putting so much into it,
but all of these things
will also let off a lot
of their own juices.
So even though
we're not starting
with a huge amount
of broth-- like,
the mushrooms are
going to release juice
and will create a stock
kind of all on their own.
So once it's all together,
it will be a brothy dish,
but it will have a fair amount
of vegetable in there as well.
Do you want to go for the rest?
NICK BALLA: So finally, we'll
put in some spice stuff.
We usually process most
of our spices in house.
These are bay leaf that
we dry at the restaurant.
Toasted caraway.
Finally, we're going to
put some paprika, one
of the most important
ingredients in our larder.
We got this paprika
from-- it's really
important in central
European cooking.
We spent years looking for--
following the vein of, like,
wanting to process
everything ourselves,
we were looking for
a pepper that we
could grow in California that
would produce a paprika that
was of the quality of
the European paprikas.
Because we hadn't tried
anything in the United States
or in this hemisphere that
had been of that quality.
So one year, we planted, like,
40 different types of paprika
at one of our [? ascribed ?]
winery in Sonoma.
CORTNEY BURNS: Originally
in our apartment.
NICK BALLA: Yeah,
we started them
in our apartment in the
Mission at the time, yeah.
And then finally ended up
finding one seed from a paprika
plant from Hungary, which we
spent a couple months, like,
picking-- it was a
chili flake packet.
So we ended up picking these
flakes out and planting them.
Over about a few years, we
had a couple different farmers
growing them for us.
So now we're doing a couple
thousand kilos a year
for powder, for paste, drying,
just for using-- for lots
of different things.
We do a lot of chili paste.
But super important ingredient.
And it's great in this soup.
CORTNEY BURNS: Is this what
makes them sweet and hot,
that you grabbed today?
NICK BALLA: Yeah, it's
a little bit of heat.
But the Serranos that we
put in here are also spicy.
So tomatoes, we jarred
those this last mid-fall,
when the tomatoes
were kind of peaking.
And the peppers,
these are actually
from some farmer friends in
Fresno that are still doing,
still finishing up with
tomatoes and peppers.
CORTNEY BURNS: They had
green beans a couple of weeks
ago, too, in their last--
NICK BALLA: And they're just
harvesting cucumbers now,
which is so strange
in California
how the seasons work.
So this guy's going to
simmer for a while now.
And I think we're just
going to let it go.
And maybe we get into
making some salad, yeah?
CORTNEY BURNS: Does
anyone have any questions,
comments about the soup?
Did anyone grow up eating
a sauerkraut soup or kind
of a sweet and sour
soup of this nature?
No?
NICK BALLA: This
is peasant food.
It's the stuff we crave and
really want to be eating a lot.
And it gets better.
You make a huge pot like this,
it gets better in the fridge.
Or it gets better
after several days
of just kind of sitting it.
Everything breaks down and--
CORTNEY BURNS: --melds.
NICK BALLA: This is a meal
with a chunk of bread.
You don't need anything else.
Beer.
CORTNEY BURNS: It's
a meal for 100.
I'm going to cover it a
little bit to get it rolling,
so that we have some
soup to eat in a bit.
AUDIENCE: How did Bar
Tartine come about,
and where-- do you guys
still interact a lot
with Tartine itself [INAUDIBLE]?
CORTNEY BURNS: Do you
want to talk on that
or do you want me to?
NICK BALLA: Bar Tartine
started in 2006 or 2005.
CORTNEY BURNS: In 2005.
NICK BALLA: Yeah.
Chad Robertson and Liz Pruitt,
they owned Tartine Bakery.
Basically, nothing was really
happening yet in the Mission.
There was a lot of
real estate available.
I think Bar Tartine
was an empty business,
and they were kind of almost
forced into opening it.
They were like, somebody has
to put a restaurant here,
and you guys are perfect for it.
So they did and it started out.
They called it The Wine
Bar, their wine bar.
And that was kind of what
they had it in their heads as.
It was half the size it is now.
And it was just kind
of a creative space.
Like, they had, like, chefs
in and out constantly.
Like, I mean, there was--
often, that's a bad thing.
But in this place,
it actually was--
because it was kind
of a creative space
and people were just
having fun there.
I was cooking Japanese food and
Cortney was doing everything.
CORTNEY BURNS: I had gone
on restaurant hiatus.
NICK BALLA: And Chad
Robertson would come in
to the place I was
working at the time,
and we got to know
each other pretty well.
And started talking about it.
And he wanted to
re-concept the place
and start making
whole grain breads.
And I wanted to go my
central European roots.
And so, it just kind of
made sense to try it out.
Cortney and I met.
We started cooking
there together.
And that was about
four years ago.
CORTNEY BURNS: We didn't
start cooking there together.
Nick started cooking there.
I was doing other things.
And then he asked me
one day, as the story
goes, to come and
butcher a goat.
And I never left.
NICK BALLA: Yeah.
I had been there maybe a
month, and she came in one day
and just didn't leave.
CORTNEY BURNS: To make cheese
or just to start projects.
Like, we would always be talking
about all the dried spices
that we wanted to do
and all these things.
And it just kind of
made sense to start
kind of a project kitchen there.
And so that's what happened.
And we've been there
almost four years now.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Are you guys involved
with the [INAUDIBLE] space
cooking restaurant
that's coming out?
CORTNEY BURNS: We're
not necessarily--
NICK BALLA:
--operationally involved.
CORTNEY BURNS: Yeah, not
operationally involved.
NICK BALLA: We're
going to sell some--
we're going to have some
product, like the paprika we
were talking about,
we'll probably
have some spice mixes
and preserved things
and fermented chili paste over
there, that kind of stuff.
CORTNEY BURNS: Yeah.
You know, it's really a constant
conversation with all of us--
the chef that he's
brought in, too.
And kind of an idea
platform that we all
work within and together on.
But yeah, we're going to keep
ourselves at the restaurant.
AUDIENCE: What will be the
focus of the new place?
CORTNEY BURNS: It's going to be
a larger bakery space, so a lot
more bread production.
Also, larger pastry
production, lots of canning,
preserving, things like
that that can't really
happen at the space
on 18th Street
because of the size limitations.
And so it's just going to be
larger format, wood-fired oven,
and then also more food.
NICK BALLA: Breakfast,
lunch and dinner.
CORTNEY BURNS: Yeah.
And much larger
cafe space as well.
NICK BALLA: It'll be fun.
CORTNEY BURNS: Possibly
teaching kitchen.
To be determined.
See what fits.
NICK BALLA: Toss some salad?
CORTNEY BURNS: Yup.
NICK BALLA: Oh, I
didn't mean like that.
CORTNEY BURNS: Oh, no.
So I'm going to actually
watch that knife.
You can grab that.
So like Nick said,
at the restaurant,
we basically like
to make things.
That's kind of where we--
our jumping-off point.
So we create this
larder at the restaurant
that very much so dictates
what we cook at the restaurant.
So a lot of times, instead
of thinking of a dish,
we think of what do we
have and how can we use it.
So because of the
larder, we've been
able to create over the
last four years or so--
it really gives
us the opportunity
to play with
different ingredients.
So like the green
walnuts that originally,
when we first pickled
them, we didn't
know exactly what we
were going to end up
using them for-- this salad.
We were able to put them
on here, because we already
had them made.
So it wasn't like, oh, we
should make this salad,
and now we have to wait
a year in order to do it,
because we didn't
have the walnuts.
So just to run through the
ingredients a little bit,
we have Japanese sweet potato,
also called satsuma-imo.
The interior is a white
color, very sweet.
It sounds really ridiculous,
but very sweet sweet potato.
Different in aroma and texture,
really kind of lustrous
texture, compared to
some of the other ones.
Avocado.
This one is some of
our house-made feta.
So this one's water buffalo.
Don't tell anyone.
But it's water buffalo
that we're getting.
We pasteurize and then we
age it for about six months.
Sunflower sprouts,
mung bean sprouts.
We do a lot of sprouting at
the restaurant for a couple
reasons.
One, because we like the texture
that it creates, but it also
allows us to not
cook certain legumes
and make all the nutrients
a little more bio-available.
And we can go more
into detail of that
if you guys want
in a little bit.
Parsley, dill, and then
these pickled green walnuts.
Nick will tell you all
about the process on those.
We have a little bit of a lemon
vinaigrette and the fennel oil.
So another thing
at the restaurant
is that we don't use a
lot of finishing oils.
We make them.
So we start with a base benign
oil, and then we infuse them.
NICK BALLA: Instead of
extra virgin olive oil--
we love extra virgin
oil, but we'll often
make things like sunchoke
oil or fennel oil instead.
CORTNEY BURNS: Just
because it allows us
to layer in more flavors more
specific to what we're doing.
And then just a
little bit of lemon
that we'll toss with this.
Do you want to talk
about the walnuts?
NICK BALLA: So yeah,
the green walnuts.
They've kind of turned
into our-- almost
like an olive substitute
at the restaurant.
We make olives, too.
But for this salad, it's a
slightly different thing.
It's really a fun
combination with this stuff.
So like we were talking
about, usually March or April
every year, the
walnuts-- you guys
have all seen
walnuts on the tree.
They have, like, the
green husk around.
So it's not actual just
the nut with the hard shell
that you see, but
there's this whole fruit
around the outside of it.
So we're using the whole thing.
It'd be like the shell of the
walnut and the outer part.
So this is the entire thing.
So it's before the shell
of the walnut gets hard.
This is the time of year people
will take them off the tree.
Start in Nocino, which
is a liqueur that--
CORTNEY BURNS: The Italians
were famous for for a Christmas
liqueur.
NICK BALLA: What's the date?
There's one day
when you're supposed
to process it every year.
It's like a tradition.
CORTNEY BURNS: I
don't know the day.
NICK BALLA: And then
you don't use it
until, like, November,
'cause it sits and oxidizes.
But the pickled
walnuts, we take them
and we basically brine ferment
them for about a month.
So just salt brine, which
leaches out tannins,
starts to sour them and
ferment them a little bit.
But mainly, it's getting
rid of all those tannins
that are in the
skin of the walnut.
It's really, really bitter,
acrid kind of flavor.
So after that month or
so of brining and kind
of releasing their
tannins, we'll
put them in really
mild vinegar brine.
We've been using rice vinegar
with no added aromatics,
really.
The first year we did
it, we had sugar in it,
but I don't think we've
been doing any sweetening.
CORTNEY BURNS: Nope.
NICK BALLA: It
doesn't need it after.
Even in vinegar,
even though it's not
a super active
fermentation, there's
still processes taking place.
And the walnuts
continue to break down,
and the flavor develops.
So we don't usually
end up using them
until the sweet potatoes
become available in the fall.
So it's at least six months
from the time we process them
till we start using
them, usually.
And then we'll do 120 liters.
This is the longest
they've lasted this year.
I think we did a bigger
batch than we did.
CORTNEY BURNS: We did a
bigger batch this year, yeah.
NICK BALLA: But they're usually
gone in a couple of months.
So we're lucky to
still have them.
CORTNEY BURNS: They all get
poked about 8 or 10 times
before we start brining
them, so that some
of the noxious flavors come
out and then the brine goes in.
So it kind of works
from the inside out.
But you can see
the shape there, is
that's where the nut would be.
So like, that is the
walnut that you're
going to eat on your
carrot cake later.
That would be where it lived.
But when we get them,
it's just either hollow
or has just an inkling of,
like, a little almost like jelly
on the inside.
AUDIENCE: What's the
base of the salad?
CORTNEY BURNS: So
we're going to do--
so these are the sweet potatoes.
And so I peeled this one.
These have been gently roasted.
They're roasted till
they're just about tender,
but not so soft that
you could puree them.
So we're going to slice this up,
which I'll do here in a second.
We're going to layer a base
of sweet potato on the bottom.
And then we're going to slice
up some avocado over the top.
And then we have some
sunflower sprouts and the mung.
We're just going
to kind of layer
all of that in with the herbs.
We're going to spread
the vinaigrette around
on top of that and a
little bit of the oil.
And then some of
the fennel, which
Nick's going to marinate here
with just a little bit of lemon
and salt.
And then a little
bit of the walnuts,
mainly for their brininess,
but also for their salinity.
So they're a lot of the salt
that's actually in the salad.
They're creating that sort
of layering of flavor.
And then we grate
the feta, again,
kind of the saltier component
all over the top of it
with some coarse black pepper.
So it's just kind of a sandwich
salad, just kind of layers in.
You getting some
heat over there?
NICK BALLA: It smells crazy.
CORTNEY BURNS: Can
you guys smell that?
AUDIENCE: Is the
house feta less salty
than kind of traditional feta
because you use the water
buffalo?
CORTNEY BURNS: No.
I mean, we do cow.
We do water buffalo.
We do sheep.
It really just kind
of depends on what
we're working with
in the moment.
But the salinity comes into
it when we're brining it.
So the cheese itself isn't
salted kind of on the curd.
It's the brine that
we put over it.
So the first brining of it
is a supersaturated brine,
which is like 28 ounces of
salt per gallon of water, which
is a fair bit of salt.
So we do that for 24 hours.
And then we pour a completely
unsalted brine over it
again to kind of dilute it.
And then from there,
we just let it age.
So the milk itself
isn't necessarily
imparting any salt
one way or the other.
We're just going to cut
these nice and thin.
NICK BALLA: If anybody wants to
smell where this is starting,
you're welcome to pass it.
It's a little bit
warm, not too bad.
CORTNEY BURNS: So you can
see that you can still
slice through these.
If you were to cook them
all the way, it would smash.
So we take them
until they're just
kind of tender on the
outside, but still, you
feel like they're a
little bit al dente.
I mean, you can pass
them around if you
want to see where they're at.
They just start to
shrivel, but not
so much that you can kind
of push through them.
This allows us to layer
them in and also just
have a little bit of
tooth left on them still.
AUDIENCE: What got you guys
started on preservation,
putting so much emphasis
on preservation?
NICK BALLA: We grew up
with kind of central,
eastern-central European--
we're both from the Midwest,
and so our families are kind
of-- her side was like chopped
liver, and a lot
of pickles, and--
CORTNEY BURNS: Russian,
Lithuanian, Polish.
NICK BALLA: Russian, Lithuanian.
I had the Hungarian,
German, Polish,
that whole thing going on.
Grandparents that made
sauerkraut and had
a lot of pickles
and made soups and--
CORTNEY BURNS: Borscht.
My grandma was making
lots of, like, whole beet
borscht and things like that.
NICK BALLA: My mom was
a hippie, so she always
had a lot of fermented
stuff around.
CORTNEY BURNS: Totally.
NICK BALLA: Like a lot of, like,
lime pickle, like Indian lime
pickle.
And she always made sauerkraut.
She had a huge garden.
So we just kind of grew up
loving those-- loving spice
and sour and all that stuff.
So we couldn't cook
in a restaurant
and not have those flavors.
Because otherwise,
we'd get bored.
CORTNEY BURNS: We both grew
up eating whole lemons,
as well, which your dentist will
tell you is a really bad idea
and is a really bad idea.
NICK BALLA: Might have
been the candy, actually.
I was thinking about
that the other day.
CORTNEY BURNS: Might
have been the candy.
Also true.
AUDIENCE: Nick, you
mentioned that you
worked in a Japanese restaurant.
NICK BALLA: Uh-huh.
AUDIENCE: So do you
guys pickle or preserve
with all of the various
techniques from other cultures?
NICK BALLA: Oh, yeah.
Huge.
Japan, we still have a lot of
Japanese influence in our food.
We use kombu seaweed,
and dashi is, like,
one of our main ingredients.
Almost every one of our
stocks, we'll use dashi in.
We often make this soup
with dashi at the beginning,
with kombu at least.
CORTNEY BURNS: [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BALLA: Because Kombu
seaweed, it's the base of dashi
and a lot of the
Japanese flavors,
that you make goulash
at home or you
make cream of mushroom soup.
Whatever you're making, if
you put a piece of kombu
in when you start,
it's releasing umami.
It's releasing--
CORTNEY BURNS: Glutamates.
NICK BALLA: Glutamates.
Building flavor.
So there's a lot of
ways to add flavor,
to borrow flavors
from other cuisines
without making them taste
too weird or fusion-y.
A lot of these things
make sense together.
At our restaurant, we use sake.
We make koji, which is
kind of the base of miso.
We make miso.
I mean, we're playing
with soy sauce.
CORTNEY BURNS: A
little paprika paste,
but in different veins,
some that kind of nod
to the Middle East, some
that nod more to Hungary,
and then certain parts of Asia.
We're inspired by pretty much
foods from around the world.
And a lot of our cooks are
from different places as well.
So they'll be like, well,
my mom used to make this,
or my grandmother made this.
And we're like, wow,
that sounds great,
and we have no
idea how to do it.
But just from hearing what
they're talking about,
we'll take what we have
locally and just play.
NICK BALLA: Yup.
CORTNEY BURNS: So I'm going
to-- did you marinate this guy?
Is it ready to go?
NICK BALLA: I put some lemon
and a little bit of salt
on the fennel, yep.
CORTNEY BURNS: Do you
want to build the salad,
or do you want me to?
NICK BALLA: Go for it.
CORTNEY BURNS: I'm
gonna build a salad.
NICK BALLA: I'm going
to play with this.
AUDIENCE: When it comes
to building new recipes
for the restaurant, you
mentioned that you like play.
You use whatever you have
access to locally and maybe
what you guys have
produced at the restaurant.
But can you talk a little bit
about the process of-- you
have the ingredients.
You probably have a
direction you want to go in.
Can you talk about
the step after that.
Like how do you actually
get started on that recipe?
CORTNEY BURNS: Yes.
I mean, it's a very
multi-layered kind of question.
A lot of it comes down to what's
already on the menu, for one.
So if we're working
with-- we don't
like to double up on
ingredients on a menu.
So if we're really
excited about carrots,
we'll have to pull them
off from somewhere else
and then find a way to
kind of reincorporate
another ingredient.
So a lot of times, it's
kind of like playing Jenga.
So you're moving things
around in this way,
trying to get them
to all fit together,
not having too many things that
necessarily completely overlap,
but everything
that just overlaps
enough to make sense together.
Our menu's very much set up
in a shared plate format.
So you probably, at any
given time, have five or six,
hopefully, dishes on
the table that you
may be eating together.
So we always try
and keep in mind
what people are kind of going
to be eating at the same time,
so there's not too much--
dissonance can be good,
but not, like, overt dissonance.
It's good when things kind
of play off each other
and you have really
sour, and then really
gently sweet over here,
something that's really creamy.
But when creating new
dishes, a lot of the time,
I mean, for us,
sometimes it just
starts with a conversation.
Or like, hey, I happened to
cook carrots this way yesterday,
and it turned out really great.
And then it's like, oh.
And it spawns this
whole conversation.
Or we tasted something,
and that flavor
was something we
want to highlight.
So it kind of-- I
don't know if I'm
answering your
question completely.
But we draw from many
different places.
And having two people kind
of working together on a menu
can be really challenging.
So kind of we also ping-pong
back and forth ideas.
And then at some
point, one person
has to kind of make a decision.
It's sometimes really hard to
make it a collaborative effort.
So we kind of divide and conquer
ourselves a lot of the time.
But more often
than not, we start
with what do we want to eat.
So like, what sounds delicious?
And so we don't
go from, like, OK,
so I want to make this plate
that looks like a garden.
Like, that is never--
there's nothing
wrong with that
sort of approach,
it's just not how we think.
We'll be like, well, what
do we want to do with this?
And then it ends up on a plate.
We don't go the
other way around.
So we create from
flavor and then find out
how it's going to look here,
versus the other way around.
And then we also just kind
of draw from our spices
and kind of pull from there.
So does that-- do you
want to expand on that?
NICK BALLA: The
ingredients really.
It's kind of what
you were saying.
The ingredients
really dictate what
we're going to put on the menu.
So we hate the notion of,
we're going to the market,
and we're going to
buy this, and we're
going to make this
with it, exactly
with a pre-planned
notion of what
the ingredients are
going to be like.
Because you get to the market
or you get to the store,
and the stuff's different.
So you say you want to
make a tomato salad,
you get to Whole
Foods or wherever
you go, and the
tomatoes are terrible.
Don't make a tomato
salad anyway.
Make something else.
Always, always have options.
So a lot of the times,
we'll go to the market,
and we'll say we want to
get something to pickle,
and we'll see somebody
with a deal on turnips,
because they've just pulled
up their whole field.
They want to plow over the
rest of the turnips and plant
something else for the early
winter, their early spring
planting.
So the fall turnips
need to come out.
Our buddies will have huge bins
of turnips for $0.50 a pound.
Great.
We didn't know we were
going to get them today,
but all of a sudden, we
have 300 pounds of turnips.
CORTNEY BURNS: Or 500
pounds of winter melon.
NICK BALLA: Where's
that picture?
These things are insane.
CORTNEY BURNS: Nick went to
the market alone last week
and came back with, like,
1,000 pounds of vegetables.
NICK BALLA: Yep.
CORTNEY BURNS: Yeah.
NICK BALLA: So the
turnips-- we'll get back
and we'll open them up.
And we're not
automatically going
to make a turnip
salad with them.
We don't know if they're
going to be sweet.
CORTNEY BURNS: Sulphuric.
NICK BALLA: We taste
them at the market,
but we don't know
how they're going
to end up after they're pickled.
So a lot of the times, we'll
finish processing something.
So we'll pickle all the
turnips and brine ferment them
for a couple weeks.
And by the time
they're done, what
they taste like will determine
what we use them for.
So we'll often have a huge
project that's finished.
It's been doing whatever
for a couple months.
We'll taste it and then
develop a dish with that
after, not having a
predetermined plan for them.
AUDIENCE: Where do you shop?
Or is it some sort of secret?
CORTNEY BURNS: Safeway.
NICK BALLA: Everywhere.
Everywhere.
I mean, we have a
lot of relationships
directly with farmers.
We have two different
sets of folks
that are just growing
for us exclusively.
And then there's-- one
example is these girls.
And they actually
sell to a couple
of our friends'
restaurants too now.
But they're just
farming in the Mission.
They have this huge lot in
the Outer Mission, little city
gardens.
And they're growing
incredible stuff
that's climate-appropriate,
organically,
out there in Outer Mission.
Kale and chard
and lots of herbs.
And they do a lot of flowers.
CORTNEY BURNS: Radishes.
NICK BALLA: And really,
really awesome stuff.
And then the people that do most
of our paprika are up in Napa.
Justin and Mindy,
Full Table Farms.
And they're just
growing for us now.
We're basically getting
into a system with them
now where we don't
even order anymore.
We just say, just show up.
Or they kind of let us know
what they're going to have.
But it's really--
our approach is
we change the menu so often that
it's fun to just kind of say,
bring us what you need
to harvest, what's best,
and then make stuff.
CORTNEY BURNS: Most
days, it's fun.
Except when everyone happens
to deliver on the same day.
NICK BALLA: Oh, no,
it's not always fun.
AUDIENCE: I guess the
followup is where do you
put 1,000 pounds of melons?
NICK BALLA: All
over the restaurant.
CORTNEY BURNS: Everywhere.
There are still-- [? Kaitlyn ?]
can attest to this.
One of our sous chefs is in
the back helping us out today
with the food they we're
going to plate for you guys.
But yeah, it ends up everywhere.
Like, literally.
It's a problem.
We have a
vegetable-buying problem.
Like, we do.
We're known for-- with
a lot of our farmers,
they'll call us and
be like, we have
300 pounds of, like,
B grade, whatever.
You guys want it?
And we're like, yeah, sure.
NICK BALLA: B grade is
like magic to our ears,
because it's ugly on the outside
and beautiful on the inside.
CORTNEY BURNS: As long as
it's delicious, it's fine.
We can work with it.
And we really like to do that.
Granted, part of the reason
is we get a great deal on it,
which makes it really easy
for us to buy things in 500-,
600-pound increments,
where it may not be--
you go to the
Ferry Plaza Market,
you're not necessarily going
to get 500 pounds of something
for cheap.
You're going to spend
half your paycheck on it.
But we do shop at those markets.
To kind of finish
up on your topic,
we have about six
or seven farmers
that, like Nick was saying,
that we work with weekly.
Then there's the
Civic Center Market
that we like to go to
Wednesdays and Sundays.
And then there's
the Ferry Building,
Ferry Plaza Market
on the weekends.
Saturday's kind of the
best, but they also
have Tuesday, Thursday.
Just depends on what we need.
And then there's weeks
where we don't have time
to go to the market at all.
And we're lucky enough to
have a lot of our farmers
that deliver directly to us.
I'm going to keep building
this while we talk.
So this is a little
bit of fennel oil.
So we're just going to wet
these guys a little bit.
And this vinaigrette
is lemon juice, dill.
It has a touch of honey in it
and just a little bit of oil.
So it's pretty bright.
And then we add in the other oil
to kind of balance it as we go.
But it's not like an
oil vinegar vinaigrette.
It's more just kind of like a--
NICK BALLA: Can you guys see
what's going on over here?
CORTNEY BURNS: Yeah.
I'm just layering.
So the sweet potatoes are down.
I've got a little
bit of oil on them,
a little bit of vinaigrette.
Now we're going to
layer in some avocados.
We like lots of avocados.
AUDIENCE: To what degree
do business matters play
a role in when you guys are
talking about ingredients
or dishes or anything like
that at the restaurant?
CORTNEY BURNS: You
mean like food cost?
You mean like business
matters in that way?
AUDIENCE: Marketability.
Like, making sure that
people will actually
enjoy the dish and
things like that.
Because maybe there's
dishes you guys love, but--
NICK BALLA: We sit right on
the border of people's comfort
zone.
CORTNEY BURNS: In many ways.
Sorry.
NICK BALLA: Luckily-- right.
That is accurate.
Luckily, it's a very
receptive customer base,
not just in San Francisco,
but even in The Mission,
even more specifically,
where we live.
So we're really
fortunate to have that.
And just in general,
people's attitudes
about dining and expectations
have changed so much recently
in the last just several years.
I don't think this could
have worked 10 years ago.
Or it would have
been challenging.
But we have a
mainstream audience.
And for the most part,
people will get it
and are open to what we're
doing, even if we can't even
explain what it is we're doing.
CORTNEY BURNS: Yeah.
I mean, a lot of time it is
managing people's expectations.
Either if we're talking to a
table or our front of the house
is talking to a table, if we can
have them create something that
is based in something
they're familiar with
or comfortable with,
then a lot of the times,
we can kind of win
back the skepticism
that we sometimes get.
So if we explain to people
where these ideas of the dishes
are coming from.
And food is very
nostalgia-based,
so hopefully we are
creating flavors
that may be new as far as
how they're put together,
but everyone's
had a sweet potato
and an avocado and an olive.
It may be a pickled
green walnut,
but it really tastes
like an olive.
So if we can kind of explain
to people in this way--
and not to dumb it down,
but just to create, like,
a sense of comfort for people.
We're not reinventing the wheel.
We're not really doing anything
super cerebral or crazy.
We're making a sauerkraut
stew, and we serve it
at the restaurant.
It'll just have a big blood
sausage on it, too, probably.
And so it really is managing
people's expectations
and figuring out how to
create comfort for people
and what dishes are going
to make them comfortable.
And then from there,
once they kind of
trust you a little bit
more, you can bring them in
and have them taste things.
I mean, some of our food might
be seen as weird or different,
but hopefully, it doesn't
taste like something that's
like so out there that has
no basis in either reality
or some sort of flavor that
maybe you've tasted before.
Like, we find our
biggest successes
are when someone's like,
this tastes like something I
had when I was blah, blah, blah.
And we're like,
oh, food nostalgia.
There's nothing more
successful than that.
So if we are creating
food from that standpoint,
we find that oftentimes,
it has a better
chance of being successful.
Does that make sense?
So just to bring you
guys back over here,
we have the fennel, which
Nick kind of marinated
with a little bit
of lemon and salt.
And it just kind
of tenderizes it.
We've layered that over the
sweet potatoes and the avocado.
We've got a little bit
of vinaigrette on there.
And then we're going to layer
some of these walnuts on there.
I'm going to pull them
apart a little bit.
It can be really intense if
you eat too many at once.
And what we're doing
is, we're creating
that kind of salt base.
We're creating that
layer of flavor in there
and some of the acidity.
So break them up so
that you kind of get one
with every bite.
And then these
mung bean sprouts.
Dos anyone sprout at home
or familiar with sprouting?
Yeah?
What do you sprout at home?
AUDIENCE: Usually mung beans.
NICK BALLA: Nice.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CORTNEY BURNS: Oh, yeah.
NICK BALLA: Awesome.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CORTNEY BURNS:
That sounds great.
Anyone else?
It's super easy, which is great,
and really, really healthy,
and a nice kind of
textural element
that you can layer into things.
You can also cook
with them, too.
So any seeds and
different legumes
like that, they're
dormant when they're dry.
And so what we're
doing is waking them up
and asking them to give
us their nutrients.
And it sounds super hippie,
but that is what's happening.
So when we start to feed them
water, we're mimicking nature
and we're asking them
to start growing.
And what that does is
they release the nutrients
that they would need in
order to start to grow.
And then we get to eat them.
AUDIENCE: So how
would you sprout them?
Like, would you wet
a paper towel down?
NICK BALLA: For
the most part, most
of the things we do get a soak,
get soaked at least overnight.
And then depending
on, first of all,
how much we want to sprout it--
so these guys are sprouted.
These sunflower sprouts are
sprouted into long shoots.
Depending on what
we're looking for,
like these mung sprouts
just barely have tails.
So these will get
soaked overnight,
and then we'll just rinse
them a couple times a day
for two to three days.
And then they're ready to eat.
They're just starting
to form tails.
So there's a number of different
ways you can approach it.
But usually, I'll
start with a soak
and then rinsing
until they're done.
CORTNEY BURNS: So you'll
see that we're just
tearing the herbs up here,
which, again, we were
talking about before, running
your knife over, tearing herbs.
Some kitchens, you would
totally be kicked out of.
But we're just
opening up the flavor.
And we don't really
need them to be
finely diced or
anything like that.
Just tear them.
It works great.
But yeah, someone
else would definitely
tell you that it's illegal.
AUDIENCE: Question.
Do you guys have any issues
with the Health Department
or any of that kind of stuff
with fermenting and sprouting
or any of those things?
It's all good to go?
NICK BALLA: We hope so.
CORTNEY BURNS: So far so good.
NICK BALLA: We're lucky to
have a really cool guy that's
doing it.
Our particular
inspector has really
been open-minded
to-- like, I think
that we would probably
get shut down in New York.
They're pretty
tyrannical over there.
For the most part,
like fermented stuff,
like sauerkraut, there are
no documented instances
of food-borne illness
from a lactic ferment.
You don't get sick
from sauerkraut.
That just does not happen.
We have an interesting
relationship
with this stuff,
where people-- even
when we started doing
it-- like kimchi.
I remember making kimchi
and being terrified
I was going to poison
somebody 10 years ago,
or whatever it was.
It's just not going to happen.
People get sick
usually-- I mean,
I'm not saying it's
completely impossible.
But as far from
pathogens, it doesn't
happen from brine ferments.
CORTNEY BURNS: You're
more likely to get sick
from the raw cabbage than you
are the fermented cabbage.
So if there is something
on the raw vegetable,
you'll hear people getting
sick from lettuce at times.
NICK BALLA: You're going to more
than likely get food poisoning
from improper handwashing
of somebody's Romaine salad.
Or you hear about
these different scares
from different large,
huge farms that
get E. coli contamination
and things into their greens
or broccoli.
There's been spinach--
that's the most common stuff,
handwashing.
CORTNEY BURNS: But if you
brine ferment those things--
NICK BALLA: It kills everything.
CORTNEY BURNS:
You're good to go.
NICK BALLA: Except for
the lactic acid bacteria,
which we like.
CORTNEY BURNS: Yeah.
So we're going to grate
some feta over this.
And we're just going
to use a grater.
This is a really
hard form of feta.
Sometimes you can find softer.
Anything.
You could buy crumbled in
the store and recreate this.
You, by all means, don't
have to sprout anything.
You could use any lettuce
that you like on here.
So again, it's a template.
We're saying, we like sweet
potatoes and avocados.
Beyond that, go for it.
You want blue cheese on
it, put blue cheese on it.
All of our recipes
are really templates.
It was really
challenging for us--
one the most challenging
things about writing the book
was actually writing
the recipes, because we
don't necessarily cook that way.
And it's always changing.
And there was times where we had
to just kind of stop ourselves
at some point and be like,
well, yes, we found a better way
and we like it more like this.
But our publisher
will kill us if we
keep changing the recipes.
So we really encourage
people to use them
as templates, learn
the techniques,
and then from there, really
to play with the recipes
as they are.
So like this, say
we run out of feta,
we'll turn it into
something else.
But this is how it is on
the menu at the moment.
And this is also
what is in the book.
So that's kind of how
we finish that salad.
So again, really kind of rustic.
Like, you don't really
know what's in there.
But that's kind
of the fun of it.
So you can do this
at your dinner party
and be like, see, I made
you this beautiful salad.
You're not sure what's on
it, and I didn't screw up
the plating of it, because I
just covered it completely.
If you take nothing
else from this today,
grate cheese over the
top of everything,
and it'll look beautiful.
You want to take the
cheese, [? Kaitlyn? ?]
NICK BALLA: These
guys look hungry.
CORTNEY BURNS: Yeah.
You guys can start plating?
NICK BALLA: Does anybody
have any more questions?
AUDIENCE: Going back
to the ingredients
that you said that you
just pick up in huge bulk,
is there ever a situation
where you brine it
and then you just
realize it doesn't work,
or the flavor's just
wrong, or it's too similar,
and you have to just
throw a huge amount away?
AUDIENCE: Can you
repeat the question?
CORTNEY BURNS: Sure.
We're being asked if
we've ever picked up
a huge batch of
vegetables, taken the time
to peel them, brine
ferment them, sit on them,
and then realize that
they're not delicious.
NICK BALLA: All the
time, and it's always
our fault when it happens.
The reason is if
we buy something
that looks beautiful--
and this happens
at the farmer's markets a lot.
It looks awesome, and you
didn't really taste it enough,
and you didn't
really pay attention
that the center is
woody or bitter.
And then you wait
two months, and you
have this awesome
pickle, and then
it all goes in the garbage.
And that happens more
than it should have.
Not frequently.
CORTNEY BURNS: We often find
something to do with it.
NICK BALLA: But there
have been, like,
60 liters at a time
of things that we've
bought in quantity that
have been not usable.
CORTNEY BURNS: We
just figure we're
feeding the compost bin
every now and again.
We have to find a
way to think it's OK.
And we're like, it's
really good for the earth
or wherever it's going.
NICK BALLA: You say that?
CORTNEY BURNS: I did.
That just happened.
I say that.
But something that we've seen
is if the texture's not great,
we'll also be like, OK, let's
see if we can save it first.
There's times where it's
absolutely unsalvageable.
And you're just like,
this is not delicious.
I'm not spending
my time on this.
It's not worth it.
It'll be fine in the compost.
C'est la vie.
NICK BALLA: We'll catch
ourselves sometimes
with something that's maybe
not perfect or a little bit
mediocre.
We'll be like, maybe we could
roast it and put some sauce
on it or something.
And then it might be--
and then it's like, no.
There's no point in
starting with something
unless it's really
good to begin with.
CORTNEY BURNS: That's the thing.
In the world of fermentation
or something like that,
if you don't start with
something delicious,
you're not going to end up
with something delicious.
So like Nick said,
we make the mistake--
if we are trying to make
something delicious that's
ultimately not starting that
way, it becomes a challenge,
and we sometimes just
have to kind of pull
the cord on that one.
But we have had instances
where, like, squash may not
have the best texture,
and so we pureed it
into this fermented paste that
we've actually then recreated.
NICK BALLA: Turned it into,
like, a signature thing.
Yeah.
CORTNEY BURNS: Yeah.
And we use it as a bread dip.
NICK BALLA: We did a
whole butternut squash
that-- it would keep its texture
if you don't leave it out,
but it fermented a little
bit warm in the fall
that week or whatever.
So the texture of the
squash got really soft.
And we ended up pureeing it.
And now it's like this
awesome bread dip.
CORTNEY BURNS: Now we actually
ferment things for it.
NICK BALLA: To puree.
CORTNEY BURNS: So
sometimes-- I mean,
we learn a lot out
of mistakes or things
that not intended for, that
something wasn't intended for.
I would say we probably learn
the most from that sometimes.
And then from there, we
create all these new things
based on it.
And it's laughable
at some point,
because you're
like, oh, remember
when we tried to
throw that away?
But two years later,
we're then still creating
that same exact thing.
So we should marinate all that.
AUDIENCE: Nice.
CORTNEY BURNS: Yeah.
So it does happen, but we
try to find the good in it
and not waste too much.
It's really something that
we stand tried and true
behind at the restaurant,
is finding a way
to use more or less everything.
Because it kind of breaks our
heart to throw away something
that could be used
to feed people.
So we do our best to make use
of as much of an ingredient
as we can.
NICK BALLA: Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: There's
such a thriving chef
community in San Francisco.
Is there a lot of
learning back and forth
between different
restaurants or chefs coming
into your restaurant?
Are you guys--
NICK BALLA: We steal whatever
we can from other people.
CORTNEY BURNS: We're
really lucky these days.
Like you said, we
have a great community
of friends and colleagues.
And 10 years ago, there
was a lot more secrets
in the culinary world.
20, 30 years ago, people guarded
their signature dishes really
close to their heart.
NICK BALLA: That era is over.
CORTNEY BURNS: That
era is very over.
And a lot of it-- I mean,
you guys can all definitely
understand this, is like,
technology and the web
and all of these things, it's
like every recipe is out there.
You want to know how this
person made their custard?
Well, most likely,
you can Google
it, which is now like
a verb, which is great.
And you can find
out most things.
And so I think with that
sort of kind of condensing
of the world in general,
has allowed a lot of people
to just kind of break down
their walls in that way.
And there's so many new things
going on and so many chefs that
are playing, that
we are lucky enough
to have friends kind of
who we bounce ideas off
of all the time.
We were lucky to go to a
friend's restaurant opening
last night.
And we were sitting at a table
with some of our chef friends.
And we spent half
the time-- well,
what did you do with that?
I mean, totally nerding out.
Like, it's full-on
food nerd central.
And we get really
excited about it.
They're like, I ground the
chicken, and then I steamed it,
and then I shoved
it in the ricer.
It was like katsuobushi.
And it's like, well,
what if you did it with--
and there was a few
other people who
were sitting at our
table that are not chefs,
and they're just like-- you can
see the birds just chirping.
I mean, they're
interested, but, could we
talk about something else?
And so, when we get
together with those people,
that's kind of
what we talk about.
We had a phone call on
the way here-- a friend
who's going to
start making kefir.
NICK BALLA: In Chicago.
CORTNEY BURNS: A chef friend.
Yeah.
He's like, hey, can you tell me
what you guys have been doing,
because I know you've been
doing kefir for a while.
And it's like, of course.
I mean, yeah, sure.
And I'm going to
call you and ask you
how do you make your paprika
salami taste so good,
and how long are
you paddling it for?
And so, yeah, we're really
lucky to have that relationship
these days.
We feel really
fortunate to have it.
AUDIENCE: About bread.
Since bread is such
a big part of food
in general, and
especially at Tartine,
with the association
with the bakery,
with the surge in
gluten-free menus
and dishes and things like
that, how do you guys see that?
What's your take on
people who choose
to be gluten-free, not
because of dietary reasons,
but because they just choose to?
CORTNEY BURNS: I think everyone
has a choice on what they eat.
Like, I, for instance, have
to taste a lot of gluten.
But for full disclosure,
like, I do not
eat the bread at the restaurant.
I will taste it if
they've made a new loaf
or there are really
cool grains in it.
But it doesn't make me
actually feel great.
This took years of not feeling
great to kind of figure out
what was going on.
And so I just don't
do that to my body.
But when I go out to eat, if
something's hidden in there,
I know enough about food
to be like, I bet you
that's got that in that.
Or also just to ask.
And I'll order something else.
My only issue is
when people always
want what they can't have.
So you're like,
well, this dish you
can't have, because it has--
of the nine components in it,
five of them do
have gluten in it.
But they want that dish anyways.
And it's like, let
me give you something
that you can have as
we intend it to be.
We'll pull stuff out.
Whatever, that's fine.
People have dietary
restrictions,
we deal with it all the time.
No big deal.
But let us try to curate for
you, so that we can guide you
in the best way, so
that you actually
have an experience that might
be as much as we intended it
to be, or at least as much
as we intended it to be,
instead of having to
recreate something
on the spot that has nothing
to do with anything that we're
doing.
But some of our
most fun moments are
when someone's like,
well, I'm this, that,
and the other thing.
And they have a
serious health issue,
and they can't
have this or that.
And on the spot, we have
to come up with a dish,
and sometimes it ends
up being-- not always--
but sometimes it ends up being
the best dish of the night.
Because you just have to
really be on your toes,
and you get to just kind of make
something totally different.
So it kind of has
both ends to it.
But there are nights where
it's like 90% of the people
have some sort of
allergy or aversion,
and it does start to wear
on you at some point,
because you're
just like, really?
Are you allergic to onions or
you just don't like onions?
You know?
Or you get the gluten-free
people who then eat the bread.
And you're just like, I don't
totally understand this one.
But you know what?
It's like, we all
get our choices.
We all get to be who we are.
And so it's just--
as much as we can,
we just try and let
people do their thing.
There's only so much
you can do about it.
And there's only
so much energy you
can spend being
frustrated by it.
It's really a waste of
time most of the time.
NICK BALLA: You're doing great.
CORTNEY BURNS:
You're doing great.
You look great.
Yup.
Anyone else?
Does anyone avidly cook at home?
AUDIENCE: Anyone what?
CORTNEY BURNS:
Avidly cook at home?
Yeah?
Hence why most of you are here.
But that's great.
That's something that we feel
is missing a lot from kind
of our modern
landscape, and we hope
that people are getting back to.
And that's a huge reason
why I put that big technique
section in the front.
It's just to give people
even more of an opportunity
to play at home.
It's like, if you want to
make the yogurt, you can.
You can also buy it,
because there's really
good yogurt in the marketplace.
But if you want to know how,
it's all kind of in the-- not
all-- but a lot of
it's in the book.
And it's definitely
not all-encompassing,
but it's kind of the
starting guide to utilizing
the techniques that
are in the recipes
in the back of the book.
But yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have substitutes
for some of your ingredients?
Like it would be really hard
to get the pickled walnut.
CORTNEY BURNS: No, you
can order them on Amazon.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
CORTNEY BURNS: So
what's interesting
about the pickled walnuts
is it's not something
we created at all.
And most of the
things in the book
are not things that we just had
some sort of amazing epiphany.
That's just not how it is.
It's like, oh, all
over parts of Britain,
people are eating this with
boiled meat as we speak.
Do you need these?
Do you need this?
Do you need everything?
Do you want this?
This is [? Kaitlyn. ?]
She's one of our sous chefs.
[? KAITLYN: ?] Hi.
CORTNEY BURNS: Life would
not be the same without her.
So you can order them,
and they come in a jar.
AUDIENCE: What was the question?
NICK BALLA: Amazon Prime.
She's asking, do we have
a lot of substitutes
in the book for
hard-to-find ingredients.
And we do.
And some of them-- it won't
always be stated exactly,
but we try to get kind
of a general idea of what
it might be like.
We didn't actually put a
sourcing section in our book,
mainly because most people are
so internet-savvy these days
that they'll just go on
their Google home page
and check it out.
So most things can
either be bought,
or some sort of substitute
can be made, yes.
It's few and far between on
the things that can't at all.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Well,
everyone, thank you
all so much for coming.
If we could please
thank Cortney and Nick
for this wonderful demo.
CORTNEY BURNS: Thank you guys.
[APPLAUSE]